hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well at a certain
point in the defense speech which
Socrates is giving any is on trial for
his life recorded in Plato's apology
Socrates actually takes on one of his
younger accusers a young man of Athens
from a noble family named mellitus and
the charges that have been brought
against Socrates the official charges
are of corrupting the young corrupting
the young men of Athens and impiety and
I'm going to look at and Piatt another
core concept video this one is focusing
on Socrates responses and the arguments
that he's making in response to this
young man mellitus he's leading him
through some some back-and-forth
dialogue what we call cross-examination
almost and he brings up a number of
interesting points and first he actually
accuses the latest of not really being
that that interested in or that that
occupied with let alone competent in
talking about these topics of corrupting
the young he says malaysia's you never
actually gave any thought to this so
you're not really a competent observer
he's talking to the people
jury as well when he's doing that I have
three arguments here three main
arguments that Socrates makes each
argument should culminate in the idea I
don't actually deserve to be charged
with this I'm innocent of this charge so
the first argument he asks my latest
there's this actual dialogue you're some
back and forth he says so let me ask you
you're saying that I corrupt the young
people the young men there's an opposite
to corruption which is improving who
improves the young people and Malaysia's
first gives a sort of stock the answer
that was common among Greek city-states
at the time the laws the institutions
it's the city itself which does that and
so Socrates says well I'm not asking you
about laws I'm asking you who actually
who can you point to that actually
improves the young people and milena
says well all of your fellow citizens
you know the people on the jury
remember juries at that time we're not
we're accustomed to 12 people in a
courtroom but rather it was the right of
Athenians to participate in judicial
deliberations so this is a large
assembly and so he's saying essentially
all the people of Athens that have a
certain amount of property all the
people that can participate in politics
the Commerce the culture of Athens any
one of them improves the the young
people how do they do that you know
through traditional education through
modelling through interaction and so
Socrates now has him because he's going
to say so let me get this straight
mellitus everybody else
improves the young all the other
citizens of Athens you know he's putting
aside people who are resident aliens you
know Sophists people like that all of
them improve the people of Athens
including the poets including the
playwrights including the craftspeople
including all the politicians but I'm
the guy who corrupts the voices yeah
that's it exactly so then the Socrates
says well that's a little strange
because in pretty much every other field
that we can look at there is somebody
who actually knows what they're doing
and they tend to be the people that
actually improve whatever it is that
they're working on and then there's the
rest of us rum gums and we're liable to
screw things up so you know if you think
about for example medicine do you just
go to anybody and say look you know I
think I might have appendicitis but I'm
not quite sure
it really hurts a lot I've looked at
WebMD what do you think what I do know
you actually go to the doctor or you go
to the emergency room you go to some
sort of expert because Joe Blow off the
street is liable to give you advice that
will get you killed
or you know damage your body even
further what about finances do we do
this you know do we just go up to
anybody on the street and say you know I
just got an inheritance so I just want
to lottery I need to think about how to
invest my money what are your opinions
on that we don't even do this with
politics which is a bit more of a you
know area where we think that competence
tends to be widespread
we don't go to just anybody we tend to
go to people that we we think have some
sort of basic understanding of that so
Socrates is saying he actually uses an
example of horses here do would you take
your but we could think about in terms
of vets if you have a dog or cat would
you just take your sick dog or cat -
uncle Ralph or you know Jim down the
street or just walk around with you know
your cat you know maybe in a knapsack
and go up to people say feel-feel kitty
cats head here how is he doing what do I
need to do different food maybe make
them run more leave them alone
I don't really know does it get more
sleep does he need less sleep no you
actually go to a vet because the vet can
actually improve the condition of the
animal so we think about human beings
that way and we think about moral
qualities as a matter of improvement or
corruption you'd think that you couldn't
just go to anybody
and get you know some improvement as a
matter of fact it's probably the other
way around now Socrates is not saying
that he's the one guy who actually does
know as a matter of fact throughout this
dialogue he's saying look there's a lot
of things that don't know but I'm at
least cognizant of my own ignorance as
opposed to these other schleps over here
who think that they know it all and are
likely to screw things up so that's
that's the basic argument that's being
made saying latest this is this is not a
likely case that I'm the only person
who's corrupting the young by way of
analogy to every other field of human
endeavor and interest it looks like it's
more often that the many aren't making
things better now that's not a decisive
knockout blow this one's a little bit
stronger
he asked mellitus you say that I corrupt
the young people right and Malaysia says
yeah you're doing it all the time so
then Socrates says do I corrupt them
knowingly do I do I know that I'm
actually making them worse and Malaysia
says yes that's that's part of why we
need to execute you we need to get you
off the scene because you know what
you're doing and then Socrates says do I
do it willingly now you know the Greeks
didn't have exactly the same conception
of the will that we do later on the word
there is more one of the lines of you
know voluntarily or is it coming from me
or is it coming from something else you
know Aristotle later on will say
compulsion or ignorance could excuse a
person remove their culpability Socrates
is asking them am i choosing to damage
these young people and milena says yes
that's exactly what I'm saying so once
again Socrates has gotten him to make an
admission that's going to lead down the
rabbit hole of argumentation and
Socrates says well you know when we
damage people are we making them worse
or better and here there's a little bit
of a play on word
a little bit of equivocation going on
but I think that you can see past that
if I have my neighbor and I make my
neighbor worse off
morally I corrupt them for example this
isn't an example that Socrates uses but
you could think about this let's say I'm
a swinger and I want to sleep with my
neighbor's wife and I'm married myself
and let's say I'm an inconsistent
swinger I want to sleep with other
people's wives but I don't want other
people to sleep with my wife
and so I corrupt my neighbor and I say
you know you really ought we ought to
share wives meaning that you ought to
share your wife with me and I get his
wife on board with that and I made them
morally worse at least by certain
standards right and now I I started
doing that sort of behavior than the
neighbor says yeah that sounds great
now I'm going to sleep with your wife
now Oh Oh buddy I'm not really good I'm
not going for that the neighbor can say
well you know you're a hypocrite you're
inconsistent but the neighbor can also
say look you're the one who actually
told me that this is okay for me to do
I've corrupted my my neighborhood we can
think about this with stealing we're
gonna think about this with lying we can
think about this with anything that
people generally frowned littering
you know if I'm if I'm telling my my
child go ahead and litter all you want
it'd be kind of silly for me to complain
about the fact that the living room is a
mess that there's candy wrappers and
coke cans everywhere right that's what
Socrates is getting at he's saying don't
you realize that if I were willingly and
knowingly making people bad and not just
people across the ocean and Egypt or
down there in Sparta but people in my
own hometown if I was making the young
people the people that are going to be
around for a long time the people who
have lots of energy if I'm making them
bad I'm setting a trap for myself I'm
actually making conditions worse for
myself and that's totally irrational how
would somebody knowingly or willing
we do something which is going to be
destructive to their own interests like
that and then here he actually says to
my latest look either you can have that
I am knowingly doing it in which case
your argument falls apart completely
because of what I said or you can say
that I don't really know what I'm doing
in which case you shouldn't be taking me
to trial you should actually be teaching
me you should be improving me yourself
instead of making me worse off by trying
to put me on trial and potentially kill
me that is a pretty good argument there
there are some some flaws that you could
put out with it but it is a pretty good
argument the third argument that he
makes it's a little bit later on he's
quit cross-examining mellitus and now
he's reminding the people of the jury
and he says look out there at your
neighbors
some of you were young men who hung out
with me and presumably if mellitus is
right I was doing the same thing back
then as I am now to the young people
talking with them you know helping them
to live a self-examine life teaching
them how to cross examine people sort of
by example I must have damaged them that
I must have damaged that guy and that
guy and he picks people out by name he
says even mentions Plato in this one
which is kind of interesting then he
says these are all adults now so
presumably if I damaged them if I hurt
them if I made them worse off why aren't
they complaining why aren't they
bringing a lawsuit against me saying
that guy Socrates he told me that this
was the way to live and I did live that
way and a man just messed up my life or
he messed up my relationships or he
messed up my wealth or he messed up my
body
none of them are saying anything like
that none of these adults who've
actually presumably benefited from being
in contact with Socrates turned out to
have been corrupted he says well maybe
you know maybe I screw
them up so much that they don't even
realize that they're screwed up but what
about their friends and relatives
they're out there in the audience too if
I screwed up and he doesn't actually you
know talk about Plato this way but if I
screwed up that guy Plato
why didn't Plato's dad say hey you need
to quit hanging around with this
Socrates guy because he's messing you up
why didn't play toes brother saying that
why didn't Plato's friends why does it
just now whole latest that somebody is
coming on the scene after I've been
doing this for you know decades saying
yeah you're messing up the young people
now that's a pretty good argument as
well in part because Socrates conduct as
he's making clear has been consistent
over decades so if he has if he isn't
corrupting the young right now
presumably he's been corrupting the
young for several decades for several
generations and there should be some
empirical evidence of this and we'll
latest can't provide that you put all
three of these arguments together and
this is a pretty pretty strong defense
against the charges that he's corrupting
the young